josh fleming will be the man for the
tampa bay rays the lefty
a season ago was simply sensational
seven games
five of them starts a perfect 5-0 record
gallow
257 average so far he hits his ball
sharply
into right field and right through the
defensive ship
one ball in two strikes on adolesce
garcia
and now a tap that's going to be fielded
by fleming and the toss
over to diaz no runs
[Music]
making his third start as a ranger
full count on meadows this one
out to center field hanging up a little
while for tavares
and he makes the play one gone
two away and the base is empty brandon
lau and that one
on the ground out to second base solak
positioned well and it's a one
two three bottom of the first inning for
kohei ari hara
it'll be low solac and heim for the
rangers here in the first half of the
second inning
this one is in the air carrying pretty
well back to the wall
and that is gone
[Music]
low just sneaks it out for a solo home
run
and the rangers jump out tonight one
nothing
hits fourth long ball of the year well
perhaps nate lowe getting hot again
as well and no better team to do it
against than his
former team well i'm nobody on it now
jonah hein
and the big cut in the miss big swing
right there
and he is out on strikes and this is
going to be the cutter away to close him
out change-ups away
he moved the ball all over the zone and
that at baddie changed speeds
so amanda first with two gone a run home
leote tavares
ground ball back to the mound halfway to
first and the toss in time
they get the one run on the nate low
homer bottom of the second coming
and joey wendell joey hitting 308
and he lines it up the right field line
down into the corner gallows gonna have
to make the pickup have some trouble
and boy they had diaz linares had him
coming home
and diaz stopped at third and could not
restart
initially he held him up okay misses
location with the fastball in on wendell
wendell turns and burns
into the corner at this point he is
being held up
after that he's being waived
you're going to see him wave yeah see he
didn't see him because initially
he was holding him up second and third
nobody out for margot
[Applause]
this could be yet another break coming
in for it
garcia great arm not that it was going
to be necessary
no one going anywhere so brings up the
struggling
to tsugo and got him swinging oh boy
a fly out into short left and then a
strike out of tsutsugo
and arya hara might be able to wiggle
off the hook here
big o2 pitch got him swinging
two strikeouts in the inning for ari
hara
and he leads him at second and third
paul who chopped when the third his
first time
chop to short this time adamas
takes care of this here's joey gallo
gallows singled his first time
the one concerning thing the other
concerning thing about that second was
the 29 pitches made by
fleming there's a little pop but he
comes back with a one two three
inning here in the third now back to the
top side here is austin meadows hari
hara has given up a home run as here's a
swing a looping line drive down the
right field line
that's going to get down for a hit
gallow over to the corner to go get it
before it rattles along the wall
and fires a bullet to second base to
keep meadows
to a one-out single here's randy or
rosarina
he chases strike three and that is the
second out of the yenni
brandon lau takes one of the dirt and
that one gets past time so meadows
moves up to second one will be a wild
pitch
2-0 and that ball hit hard out to right
field
gallow is there and that will end the
inning and so the raids leave another
man in scoring position three innings in
the books
here's nick solac
solac lifts a high fly ball
margot makes the call to the catch and a
quick fourth
graves will have jandy diaz coming up to
lead off the home half of any four two
days ago
it was two hours and 42 minutes last
night 243.
i think 244 in the air toward the corner
gallow reaches out and makes a galloping
catch
for that fly ball by diaz for out number
one
it's a nice job by joey gallo tracking
this
baseball and then trying to figure out
where the wall is while not slowing down
and making sure
that you can get to it it's also going
to be slicing away from him and you can
see it there and that's why
the long reach came into play all right
zero
slowing down but understanding you know
you're getting close now it does look
like a pretty
squishy wall they have there manuel
margot
next up for tampa bay 2-2
and a swing and a miss fourth
strikeout of the night for arihara
here's culberson
we walked his first time up on the
ground right side and that one is
through for culberson he had a three hit
night yesterday he's been on twice
coyote tavares swaying and a mess
it's nicely done that was not the
prettiest
of swings and he just completely ties
him up
first pitch rolls it up the middle
sliding to his left solac throws him out
two up two down in the fifth nick solac
trying to explain it it felt a little
bit like a slip and slide let's see
did look fun and a very nice story he
actually slipped afterwards i think
maybe was
what he was talking about watch him get
around this ball very nicely the slide
but as he goes to throw it
kind of falls down again a little sniper
got him good defense tonight behind
the 2-2 pitch oh got him swinging
a strikeout ends the fifth gallo who's
one for two
this one is low ball four so an
infield hit and a walk that may be how
fleming's night ends
it is kevin cashion it is the second
visit of the inning so
that's it for fleming chris mazza will
be the relief pitcher in this sixth
inning inherits a couple of base runners
nobody out up the middle that's a base
hit
tall into third base and they'll hold
him so the bases are
loaded with nobody out well nate lobats
that's a fair ball out in first gonna
have to get the tag
at the plate and save the call
sam holbrook came up with a safe call
mike zanino
almost immediately looked toward the
dugout diaz with his momentum going get
one out get the ball
home and let's see that tag not quite
there that
foot does not get to the oh yeah it
never got to the back he's out that'll
be quick and easy
yeah he's out runners at second and
third now
here's solac and to chop left side of
scoop by window
rays get out of that base has loaded
nobody out
and texas does not score
one two bouncer left side of the infield
and connor falefa makes it two up
two down and in fact now that is
ten straight retired by arihara let's
start
talking about a seventh inning coin yeah
he's done it
i tried john king coming on
out of the bullpen here with the six
king on here to pitch to uh brandon lau
there's a swing into this at the
fastball a strikeout of lau
and the inning is done now we'll deal
with the left-hander
david dahl and isaiah's running and that
one
down toward the right field corner
brings home a huge insurance run in
solace
here comes connor falefa he'll score
easily
a two-run double for david dahl and that
is a
huge hit in this one tonight so dull at
second
gallow at first as garcia lifts this one
high into the air fairly deep right
center field a rose arena and margot
looking up
this one it either hits in the seats or
the top of the wall what is it
[Applause]
racing to third is garcia the throw
comes in
now he's going to try to score the throw
home garcia dives he's safe at home
they're going to go ahead and challenge
him i guess why not go ahead and take
the chance let's take a look
oh right off the top of the defense wow
now let's take a look at the play at the
play oh that's
really close nice call from that angle
yeah well sam holbrook had a really good
look at it this time compared to the
last play you see joey letting him know
yeah just a matter whether or not those
fingertips got down
and they're going to stay out at the
plate
brandon loud to lead off the first pitch
has skied back into deep right
that's got some carry and is out of here
home run brandon loud the first pitch
hits his first home run of the year and
you know that that cody given that five
run lead he's going to be challenging
with the fastball so brandy lau can lay
and wait for it he got a good one to
handle and handle it he did
it's 5-1 rangers two outs in the ninth
the runner at first
and there's a swing and a miss cody
strikes out tsutsugo on an off-speed
pitch to end the game
one run two hits one left the rangers
win it five to one